mehr ja es gibt eine frage die
wahrscheinlich zu den schwersten zählt
ich kann sie nicht beantworten aber
vielleicht du was bringt menschen
wirklich zum lachen das scheint mir eine
ungeheuer schwere antwort zu sein
frankreich weiß nicht ob das die lösung
ist ich glaube dass menschen
unvollkommenheit zum lachen bringt und
scheitern in einem nicht so dramatischen
sinne sondern das ist so die kleinen
missgeschicke sind
wo der herr das ist so schwer zu
erklären aber sind die missgeschicke
passieren die irgendwie lustig sind weil
sie keine schlimme konsequenz haben und
die der mensch sich dafür schämen sollte
er darüber lachen und deswegen ist es
dass die menschen wenn man denen das vor
augen führt also ich wenn ich den meiner
eigenen unzulänglichkeit beschreibe
erkennen die sich selber wieder und
sagen mensch ich kann darüber lachen
dass es jetzt so ganz schlecht erklärt
aber lachen ist sonst kommt daher finde
ich ist so sachen die nicht perfekt sind
und deswegen lustig und manchmal auch
einfach nur geknackt manchmal ist
einfach nur geknackt und man muss
darüber lachen wie über das wort lied
aber sonst gewisse ich jetzt keine
bessere definition und ich glaube wenn
ich das lachen
durch die seele geht also für ist ja das
weißt du jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder
biologisch fängt sie am zwerchfell an
das ist ja hier unten ist jetzt meine
private erklärung deswegen ist auch
schwieriger lachen als wein also es
schwieriger menschen zum lachen zu
bringen als sie zum weinen zu bringen
weil das ist aus dem zwerchfell durch
den bauch muss wenn wir jetzt die seele
hatte ich gehe davon aus dann sitzt du
hier und da muss das lachen durch und da
kommt dann erst hier oben raus wenn du
dann hier oben noch da ist dann kommt
von ganz unten das ist super und dann
ist es meistens so slapstick ist ja dann
auch slapstick sind ja auch
missgeschicke ich glaube dass man
darüber lachen kann über sachen die
keine schlimme konsequenzen haben wenn
man muss viel mehr lachen